this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast we discuss what it
means to live a meaningful
life with less my name is joshua fields
milburn and i'm ryan nicodemus and
together we are the minimalists are you
as fascinated by dead mauls as i am
dude you sent me down the rabbit hole
well our dying malls are certainly
shaping the way we think about shopping
retail and the future of public spaces
as well one of my guilty pleasures is
hopping on youtube and
ryan has fallen down the rabbit hole
dude
i don't there's something almost
meditative about it and so i wanted to
talk today about
shopping and shopping malls later we'll
talk about a history of of shopping
malls as well and
and these spaces also where we're going
going forward
i really like just looking at some of
these decaying malls
the dead malls the dying malls
they're all three of those things are a
little bit different i think we'll be
able to talk about
the difference between actually let's
just start there so so you
there are these terms out there you hear
so this is a perfect topic for us ryan
because
this is a topic where we have a lot of
expertise especially me because i opened
a lot of retail stores but right you
opened a few as well
sure in in the corporate days and so uh
for those of you who are
unmanaged stores in indoor malls
open-air outdoor malls
yeah kiosks everything oh my goodness
and so
um at the at the peak of my corporate
career
around age 27 i was a director of
operations for 150 retail stores
now most of those were what we call
distributors some people might refer to
them as franchises
about 20 of them 15 20 were corporate
owned stores what we would call owned
retail stores now these are telecom
stores so what you would think of like
with with wireless phones but also home
phone internet
home security systems etc uh just just
technology companies
and in the the telecom realm
and and so i started in 1999
in telecom sort of worked my way up the
corporate ladder and by age 24 i
well i was store manager in my early 20s
age 24 i was a
regional manager what we call it an area
manager managing
10 to 16 stores and
i remember that all of my peers were
sort of
in their 40s or 50s i'm still not in my
40s i have
another year of my 30s left less than a
year now
but i i learned a lot through those
those peers of mine who were a lot older
who had a lot more experience
from me and so i got to sort of extract
a lot of the wisdom out of them
also our mentor our friend carl weidner
yeah who's been on
the quarantine conversations we did on
patreon had a really good conversation
with him about retail
who also specializes in malls uh
specifically leasing
yes different mall spaces right and and
so
i i've i've been in that world for a
long time i'm no longer in
that world but i still stay abreast of
it occasionally because
i find certain aspects of it fascinating
but also i find these dead malls and
these dying malls and these decaying
malls fascinating let's talk about those
three different terms
there okay because i think we often use
them interchangeably but they're three
different
things so dead mall is uh so let's start
with a dying mall
okay because that's where it really
starts the dying mall is town and
country
or tri county uh tri county now yeah
yeah can you believe trump so we're
talking cincinnati and dayton by the way
yeah uh that's what i loved about
the videos that you highlighted in the
notes was this
specifically the cincinnati uh review of
all the malls because
i i feel like we grew up uh like per
capita we had more malls than
any other state now i don't have the
data to like back that up but that's
what it certainly felt like
yeah in fact we'll put a link to in in
the show notes we're going to talk about
it during the maximal episode
uh there's a series called over mauled
cincinnati so there are three
different places i turn to to look for
these
dying mall videos the first place
is actually we're going to have kristin
on today from unicom productions
she couldn't make it in because of some
travel restrictions she had to
quarantine for a period of time so she
could go to a wedding so she wasn't able
to come out here
for that and and so we're still gonna
have this conversation because you and i
have the expertise around it we didn't
have to have an expert on here
in fact she's more of an amateur but
she's a filmmaker so she's
she's diving into these these malls so
we'll put a link to her channel
and then there are sort of two of the
ogs from the space there's
a company called bright sun films or a
guy i think his name is jake
who runs a company called bright sun
films and he does sort of history of
individual malls but not just malls or
it could be like when kmart goes out of
business or when target went out of
business in canada
yeah and and he talks about the sort of
history behind these things
and then there's the the original og
the oog uh dan bell um
he is a filmmaker who
has been documenting dying malls for a
long time in dead malls and decaying
malls so
let's get back to these terms a dying
mall is is a mall that is still
open technically you can still walk
through it yeah but it's like 10
occupancy
or it could even be 50 percent occupancy
so
middletown mall that's another are they
finally closing no if you haven't seen
the
the video on middletown mall yet no no
it's terrifying you've got to watch it
after we will after okay
we do this episode so let's cover dying
middletown is not considered a dying
mall
it probably is here's why so a dying
mall is a mall that is still open
and has fewer than 50 percent occupancy
now here's here's here are the dominoes
though most malls have
three or four anchor stores right now if
one of them goes out of business they
have to scramble to try and fill that
because
if they don't what happens is it often
causes this cascading effect through the
entire mole
right it is the the first dominant of
the fall is because as you'll recall
remember when you you manage the
fairfield commons store in
um beaver creek ohio yes it's right next
to a sears right
right well when that sears went out of
business all of a sudden that entire
wing
of the mall dies and if that wing of the
mall dies then all of a sudden you're
like oh this
is starting to become a dying crazy it
kind of shows
how so many of those stores are needless
because you've got
all these stores based off of foot
traffic from this larger store
so it's like they're hoping well you
know we're at sears we might as well
walk around this section of the mall
and oh look there's a trinket store
let's go buy a trinket yeah um
yeah it really speaks to how those
stores that closed really weren't
essential yeah and well i think that
that's a perfect metaphor
these malls are a metaphor for what's
going on
in america right now even pre coven
that sound is going to drive me crazy
yeah i know they're drilling
yeah they're they're they're drilling i
think we'll just try to talk through it
anyway
um the the
before kovid i think the the malls were
obviously dying even before covid this
whole thing is going to
accelerate it significantly yeah i've
got some stats on that we'll probably
talk about those stats on on the maximal
just for the sake of time but here's the
thing
uh you look at these malls you have
these dying malls and eventually
a mall goes out of business yes that's
when it becomes a dead mall
okay so there's a dying mall is going
out of business
a dead mall is it doesn't have to be so
you can revive there are
rare cases where a dying mall has been
revived
right and um although it doesn't always
you're the outliers
yes yeah and so so a dying mall less
than 50
occupancy a dead mall is like they shut
their doors yes okay yeah
uh or they they leave the doors open
they think of cincinnati mills uh
fairfield uh fairfield what was it
called forest fair mall
yeah oh yeah and they had like one
thing in there that yeah you could still
walk through but it was there was
still no sterno stores yeah it was a
very strange thing at one point in the
90s there was like a bunch of gang
activity there
really yeah they were like people
getting stabbed and stuff anyway
uh so yeah there was like turf wars well
i remember there was like
it was like 18 plus and they would put
these big black
x's on your hands if you were under 21
and yeah we would like go at 18 and then
go in the bathroom and wash the x's off
[Laughter]
you were like a prosthetic hand yeah
right
here's my hand sir
oh anyway all right yeah so uh and then
a decaying mall
which are i think the most beautiful
actually is
with like the dayton arcade which we're
going to talk about in a little bit
where where they've they've gone many
years usually more than a decade
of being empty yeah they begin they've
begun to decay in these sort of
beautiful
in this beautiful way where nature is
almost reclaiming it in a way
but here's the the the beautiful part
about that is sometimes these decaying
moles can be repurposed once again and
so
that's what we're going to be talking
about today you know on twitter
samira said i used to be a mall walker
at a large mall in chicago in the
chicago area and i remember the elderly
crowd
waking at 7 00 a.m before i had to go
to work i still walk in a different mall
but i can see it is slowly dying could
you imagine being a mall walker and like
every day like you're having this time
lapse
of like yeah that would be pretty
interesting i'm filming that though if
you could have filmed that for a decade
yeah we're go pro
for a decade oh my gosh that would have
been amazing
there's this modest mouse line ryan from
1997 how
uh prescient was this the malls
are the soon to be ghost towns
from 97 97 this is before
the iphone this is before the mp3 in the
ipod
did you hear about it this is before the
peripheral proliferation of the cell
phone
did you hear about the guy who invented
them all how much regret he had
yeah from the ruined effect yeah yeah in
fact i've got a whole article i want to
read on the maximal about gruen
okay and why he started the mall but
let's let's give people a little
a small history about it sure so so he
uh
he worked for the the first mall was
built by the dayton corporation which is
actually target now um but target
is you know it's a minneapolis company
so the first
the first mall first ever mall was
in minnesota oh interesting and and
happens to be where the mall of america
is too right
yes we're in fact i want to talk about
the mall america there's a new mall
called the american dream which is
hilarious we're going to talk about that
i also want to talk about the largest
mall in north america where we've given
a talk
the west edmonton mall yes uh all of
that we'll get to i think probably on
the maximum because we have some
questions
right so the history of them all the so
uh in the 50s he he
grew and did this he was an architect
and he decided that
we'll put a link to this the 99
invisible art
article that really goes through the
whole history if you're interested it's
a great
detailed article it has a bunch of
pictures and there's even a podcast to
go along with it i would encourage you
to check that out but he he set this up
as a community space because guess what
minnesota is really cold
in the winter yeah and so it was like
hey what if we created a downtown
but it was climate controlled and
indoors and you could have your post
office here you could have your
seamstress you could have your tailor
you could have a restaurant you could
you could buy flowers grocery store
yeah and best of intentions yes and then
it became
the kenwood town center and then the
corp corporate greed took over
yes yeah and and when when that happened
it pushed out because mall prices
so i'll give you a few examples here in
in dayton
for for example the more expensive
square footage like like at the green
when i was leasing stores back out
in the back in the late audi's the green
i think was 55 dollars per square foot
uh i think uh forest fair mall was sixty
dollars a square foot it was expensive
uh kenwood 110 dollars a square foot
kenwood is an interesting example of a
mall that's like still thriving
but town of country was 12 dollars a
square foot oh wow and
and so you you look at these different
places
where and you go to a strip mall it's it
and
you go to strip mall in east dayton and
it's five or eight dollars a square
foot and so there's this big disparity
so what happened is
of course your local tailor couldn't
afford
to maintain the hundred and ten dollar
per square foot
space in a mall and so all of the
community spaces were sort of
forced out because of the unfettered
capitalism
this is capitalism gone wrong you and i
are we believe that capitalism
works insofar as it's the worst system
except for
all the others right right and so we
acknowledge that socialism doesn't work
and the capitalism doesn't work and we
probably what we probably need to do is
leave both
uh both ideas behind and if there's a
way to tweeze out anything good
if we can tweeze out community aspects
from socialism
and if we can tweeze out the the market
aspects
of innovation within capitalism
then then great but if we can do that
without greed without cronyism because
that's what capitalism has turned them
into today is
crony capitalism yeah exactly and so
i i got a lot i want to talk to you
about with respect to malls but you're
right there was really good
intentions uh where it started and we'll
talk about the history we'll go go more
in the depth we're going to go into
square footage
in all of the developed world why does
america have so many
malls yeah uh there's so much i want to
talk to you about you know there's
something before we move on to these
voicemail questions i heard a line over
the weekend
i forget what radio station i was
listening to but it was an interview
with this man who said uh
society starts to decay when greed takes
over
and that couldn't be more true with
malls yeah like when the greed takes
over like that's the beginning of the
end well think about greed for a second
greed is
it says you know greed is almost
synonymous
or it's a level or two before solipsism
true solipsism
as a mental disorder is i believe i'm
literally the center of the universe and
and when we say solipsism we really just
mean
we are very self-involved we're
narcissistic selfish
yeah yeah and there's a difference
between
selfish and self-interested right yeah
and you and i are for operating our own
self-interest
sure filling up our own tank putting our
own mask on before we assist
others so to speak but if i just put my
own mask on and then i i
start raiding other people's pockets on
the plane because it's in my best
interest we're actually all just going
to die
right and and so um in a meaningful way
we have to we have to be able to think
beyond ourselves and that's why
i think a lot of this this over
indulgent consumerism
we we see these malls dying because
there's well there are a few things that
happen one is there's this over
abundance of malls they've been over
mold
and you look at a city like cincinnati
and you mention the the whole history
there but literally dozens of malls all
over the the greater cincinnati and
dayton area
and and when i look at that it's like
well some of these were
sustainable but when we we literally put
malls across the street from each other
in this in examples of kenwood and tri
county and yeah
and these different places and and don't
worry if you're not from cincinnati and
you're listening to this this isn't a
a cincinnati-centric podcast but
there are these examples but then also
our behaviors are
fluid they change over time and we built
these structures
thinking they were going to be these
permanent unmoving monuments to
consumerism
and not realizing that you know what
consumer patterns
change as technology changes as
preferences change
yeah and so i want to talk to you about
some of those spaces today let's dive
into these questions
we have a question from corinne in
charleston south carolina
i would like to ask you to help me
figure out how
to get amazon specifically whole foods
to stop delivering my groceries in
plastic they are the leading
delivery service of the nation and
everything
keeps coming in plastic and i sent a
message to my shopper i said
please do not use plastic please only
use paper i am
living as plastic free as possible and
they ignored it
so speaking of changing patterns ryan
this is one of the reasons that some of
our malls are dying and so
the reason i thought this this voicemail
stood out is we have a company like
amazon in particular now it started
before amazon obviously
right it's just like netflix killed
blockbuster right right
but there were a bunch of other things
that that were hurting blockbuster as
well the red box and all that netflix
was kind of the final nail in the coffin
and amazon is kind of the final now in
the coffin for these
uh traditional retail stores yes yeah
yeah for
for a lot of them at least right and and
so what we're seeing
here is a company who's able to sort of
dictate their own practices
and how do you get amazon to do
something
regulation so what we're this podcast is
about regulations isn't it
you're correct i would encourage you to
regulate them and actually
so i know we're saying this in jest
but you will have to regulate them but
regulating them on your individual level
means you can't
if you if this is important to you if if
shopping without plastic is important to
you then
you're going to have to find a way
around using it because apparently
they're not willing to meet your demands
yeah and if a business is not willing
to provide the product or service that
you want
you've got to find a substitute right
and the product or service you want
involves a a particular way that it's
packaged right
yeah i will say after we had andrew
mcafee on here who was an mit
scientist uh i did a podcast with him it
was
one of the few remote podcasts that we
did he's an mit scientist he's an
environmentalist he wrote
the book more from les and he has a new
essay
in wired magazine we'll put a link to it
in the show notes but
he is an environmentalist and he has
assured me that
plastic is not as big of a deal as where
we make it out to be
and i tend to trust science and
scientists yeah
now here's the thing i would prefer to
use fewer
bits of plastic whenever possible yeah i
think the message to get from it is
i'm not going to be neurotic about the
small things when there are much
bigger things i can focus my time
attention energy effort on
isn't some of the lead i'll have to
listen to that podcast isn't some of the
lessons
oh uh isn't some of the lead in the
ocean like due
to like some of the plastic pollution
not all of it but like
are some of the yeah like the big also
like the big plastic
island that they have in the sea yeah
yeah so let's talk about that yeah just
briefly
so um and this is again coming from from
andrew mcafee
and he he says hey if you want your
plastic to end up in the ocean there's
only one thing you have to do
recycle it which is terrifying to hear
he's like
he said you know personally i i will
throw my plastic away because i know
that we'll end up in a landfill and not
in the ocean well what people
understand or what people don't
understand with recycling
is that they only recycle pristinely
clean plastic so if you've got like an
indian to go container that's stained
from indian food and you put that in the
recycling bin
yes that's gonna end up not in the
landfill right and it could very
possibly end up in the ocean
and yeah the the problem is or this is
what
this is where minimalism works really
well i'm not about having a zero waste
lifestyle although i really applaud
the people who who live they try to live
a zero waste lifestyle yes
it's fundamentally impossible but it's
uh
if you can get as close to zero as
possible and bravo to you i think it's
phenomenal
but what minimalism does is i consume
less so i produce less waste so even if
i'm
if i do bring some plastic into my life
i'm bringing far
fewer things into my life thus i'm
creating
less waste whether it's recyclable waste
or landfill waste or whatever it is
it's a byproduct of consuming less yeah
so for corinne here i totally agree with
what you're saying about she
has to do the regulation herself she's
got one or two options
options she can continue to escalate
this as far as she can to
get them to stop using plastic bags but
ultimately
amazon gets to decide whether or not
they want to honor that request
and if they decide to not honor that
request then corrine if you want to live
a plastic free life or as
little plastic as possible in your life
uh
you might have to go to the store
yourself and put those things in paper
bags or reusable bags for that matter
yeah
and or find a company to whom this is
important yeah we ryan and i we work
with our friend
malcolm fontier on this bag called
packed bags
um and and so we we have you know the
this bag that showed up in our
documentary people
kept asking like uh where did you
where'd you get your bag and like i'm
like there's only 300 that were ever
made i'm sorry
um ryan and i own one percent of the
bags that were ever made
you're not gonna find one right and but
somehow people
kept reaching out to malcolm and so we
decided to partner up to to make this
bag together we did a kickstarter for it
it's still available online
if you're interested if you need a bag
here's the thing you probably don't need
a new bag
if you do it's the best bag i've ever
used but um
in the whole process we decided like
well we don't want
any plastic at all involved right in the
entire
shipping process and the manufacturing
and so what we did was we made sure
that we're not packaging this thing with
plastic we and
that's really hard because you they put
plastic on on everything
on the zippers around the bag the
wrapping the
everything isn't it unfortunate that
well hey cuz it cost us a little bit
more to do it this way
significantly so so it's unfortunate
that uh it costs more to do the right
thing
um but also you could tweet that podcast
sean
why why do companies have to be
regulated to do the right thing
or why does corrine have to be regulated
to do the right thing this is the greed
you're talking about
but here's the other part it's not just
the company
we are also greedy exactly we are asking
companies
i want it for a dollar i want free
shipping i want it in my door
in two hours that's my greed when i'm
when i'm saying i want i want this i
want it now i want it
cheaper that's me being greedy and all
the company is doing
is they are meeting my demand if we were
to go out and demand
more from our companies
then we can start to change things now
how do we do that we do it with our
wallets we have to be willing
to spend a little bit more but if we're
consuming less
considerably less we're going to split
spend slightly more
on the things that are truly important
to us but we're still going to be
spending way less money overall wow
i've never thought of it that way so we
blame corporations for their evil but
they're just reacting to the demand they
absolutely are and here's the thing if
we
if we stop demanding the cheap plastic
junk yeah
that they would stop doing it this just
goes back to i've the best way we can
vote is with our dollar
yes that is the best vote corinne i'm
gonna send you a copy of our book
minimalism live a meaningful life i'll
hold it up here for the youtube audience
if you're watching on youtube
it's the first book that ryan and i ever
wrote way back in 2011 although we
rewrote the whole thing in 2015
and it really involves well it's the
five
what we call foundational values in our
life
but it really shows you how we can focus
on
what we can control and what we can let
go
of we can let go of the rest basically
so so it shows you how to focus on the
things
that are within your control and prove
those things
and then let go of the thing it's sort
of the you know it's a book form of the
serenity prayer
control the things that you can and let
go
of of the things that you can mckenzie
in
tucson arizona has a question for us
what aspects of fashion
align with minimalism's goal of
intentionality
i have seen the two put at odds with
each other more often than not
especially with the rise of
environmentalism but think that there
must be some way to show clear
intentionality through your personal
style
so mckenzie i think that when we're
talking about fashion again this is a
good question for this because
i think a lot of our malls especially in
the
90s and the audi's and even well not
even
but especially in the 20 teens
we need a name for that decade let's
think of the teenies maybe
i like the genies i always call the the
90s the audience
yeah maybe the tinnies i don't know yeah
we'll figure it out let us know on
youtube
yeah yeah it works for everything 2000
teenies works for everything yeah 2013
to 2019. anyway
yeah so so somewhere in the 2010s there
fashion really became this fast fashion
thing
right yeah and and there's no
intentionality in fast fashion let's
let's just say that now here's the
problem i have i'm a hypocrite
because i i wear clothes that i suspect
i i mean i'm probably not right now i
don't know actually i don't know
and here's the thing um i am when you
look at your average american i'm
i'm more intentional than 98 maybe even
99
of the the populous with respect to my
fashion i try to get things that are
made in america
yeah uh i try to get things that are
even made locally and i get things that
will last me so i'm willing to pay a
little bit more
i also buy things without logos and with
that
whenever possible there are occasions
where there might be a really tiny logo
on something that i can't avoid
or i'll even remove logos whenever i can
yeah these
shoes i'm wearing here i'll hold it up
for the camera um
man these are really beat up but these
are these are tom
you know they're from amazing we got
this idea from david didn't we
david who um we stayed with him and his
girl in
san diego oh yeah yeah tooth adams yeah
and he hit tooth adams that's right on
twitter
and he uh he had a pair of toms and he
was removing
i remember him removing the tom's label
when we were there remember that but
i i the reason i did it i had a levi's
um let's see what was called a denim
jacket right that i got off ebay
and here's the ebay hack for that you
can get levi's denim jackets on ebay for
like
four to nine dollars nice but you have
to buy like
three or five of them in order to find
one that fits you right
you just buy them one at a time unless
you get the right one that fits yeah and
and but i often do even now i'll do this
with different
shirts and things is you can buy new or
next to new clothes
uh that someone bought and they just
didn't enjoy it for whatever reason
they're selling on ebay so
even with my levi's jackets i would
always just take the tag off because i
don't
that company isn't paying me to
advertise for them i wouldn't do it
anyway because advertisements suck
but so what am i going to do pay them
for the privilege of advertising
being a walking billboard on on my body
yeah there's no way i'm gonna do well
that's just the genius of marketing in
this brand recognition thing how
people want to advertise the brand
because that says something about how
much you paid for something where you
stand
you know on the socioeconomic ladder
what kind of clique you're part of
what kind of style you have um but if
we're relying on a brand
to express who we are uh
we're just expressing that we we don't
really think for ourselves yeah yeah
yeah i would encourage you to go back
and check out two episodes we did uh
number the first one is episode 56 a
long time ago ryan and i were living in
montana we did a clothing episode it's
one of our longer episodes
and it's just about clothing episode 56
and then more recently we did an episode
called fashion obsession
with tyler jones from preachers and
sneakers we talk about our sort of
obsession with fashion but to get to
your question more directly
mckenzie i think the problem we've
gotten into is we've built these
bastions of consumerism that have
required
us to consume more in order to fuel
their pockets their their bank accounts
the their corporations their ceos their
executives
and so what do they do it used to be
that we had
two seasons warm and cold
and so in the winter we had a coat or
maybe we had slightly thicker clothing
or a sweater or whatever
but now you have places like h m or
other fast fashion places
that do 52 seasons a year right
and they call them drops right and so
and they do it in ways where it's like
limited edition
trendy clothes well if something is
trendy to me that's a red flag right
away
right trendy just means soon to go out
of style what does that mean
you have to replace it yeah and if you
have to replace something constantly can
you imagine ryan if
if you bought your your toyota that you
own and
and i don't know let's say that once a
quarter you had to paint it
yeah because like there's a new cool
paint job that was in style yeah i would
buy a better
quality car right right but and here's
the thing though
it doesn't doesn't mean the paint job
was bad
we get rid of the clothes now because
it's like well that paint style
that that outer layer the paint style is
now no longer
fashionable it's no longer involved well
you know it's interesting though you
know i think that you can
intersect fashion and minimalism uh you
can totally be fashionable
and still be a minimalist uh i would
encourage um
what's her name mackenzie to check out
project 323 with courtney carver yeah
she hasn't
checked that out but yeah we in fact we
did an episode with her recently uh
within the last year
project 333 she has a book of that same
title yeah
some of the best dressed people at our
events some of the most fashionable
people at our events are doing project
333
almost always and that's the thing
because when we talk about
intentionality well what is it
it's the deliberate use of the resources
that we have
and i think one of the best places to go
shopping is not at the mall
right they're dying anyway by the way
you don't want to go to mall right now
regardless but but
you want to go shopping in your own
closet yeah because
start there yeah you have things in your
closet i did this
i know this is weird timing this is a
total coincidence but this weekend i did
it
in my own closet i have i got rid of me
i who owns next to nothing i have a
whole trash bag right now one shirt
one pair of pants and 67 jackets
[Laughter]
i'm wearing four jackets right
you now a trash bag full of uh clothes
to go donate yeah wow
sadly nothing wear jackets oh i can't
let go of my jackets
no i i i get rid of jackets all the time
we're all hypocrites man yeah
and here's the thing though like so i
was talking about the hypocrite thing
earlier is i'm very intentional with my
clothes
but still 93
of factory workers in the united states
who work under
osha conditions often in unions
often with a really good minimum wage
and other fringe benefits
93 of them say they work in sweat shop
like conditions
wow 93 of american factory workers
it's unbelievable garment factory
workers and so
yeah it's it's staggering because even
though i try really really hard to be
intentional you can only be so
intentional because the next step for me
would be what to
make my own clothes which i'm not going
to do yeah again like those corporations
they're responding to the demand
yes yeah we need it we need to demand
different things right and so
i recommend finding things that are more
timeless when i say something that is
timeless it means
for your lifetime will it will it wasn't
in style last year will it be in style
next year maybe that's the
the the good benchmark yeah and so it
could be basic colors ryan and i often
wear just black but
if purple's your color then great accent
your your stuff with dude
if i look good in purple or blue or i
would buy different color t-shirts but i
just
happen to like the way i look in black
you look great ryan so that's what i
wear
every single day what i feel best in
yeah i'm not going to switch up my shirt
because
you know my sister tells me that i look
like a goth
and she's tired of my style look at
anyone that you
that you find to be stylish from
a decade or more past so for ryan
and me that could be like paul newman or
steve mcqueen or someone like that
um and and for women it could be you
know
jackie oh and uh whoever marilyn monroe
whoever it might be
there are plenty of uh oh um who's the
novelist that i absolutely love uh
joan didion joan didion is you know she
was a
style icon look at what she was wearing
that stuff would work
today the problem is the the hype of
today
would have never worked back then but it
doesn't say supreme
how do i know i'm supreme if i don't
wear supreme mackenzie
going to send you the supreme book
it's called essential essays by the
minimalist it's a collection of 150
different essays 12 different areas of
intentional living
and one essay in here has to do with
clothing about the favorite clothes of a
minimalist i think you'll enjoy that and
the 149 other
essays that are in that book if you like
our podcast you'll like the audiobook
version of that or any of our books
or we'll send you the book book or the
ebook version if you'd like
essential essays by the minimalist uh
sean if you'd send it out to her i'd
appreciate it ryan what time is it you
know what time it is it's time for our
lightning round where we answer your
text
messages text your questions and
comments to
four six five 937-202-4654 yes indeed
those texts go to both of our phones and
we personally reply
to as many as we can so you can text us
our questions your questions even if
we don't answer them here on the air
we'll text you back in in some form or
fashion now during the lightning round
so ryan and i do our best to answer
every question with just a short
shareable less than 140 character
response
we put the text to these minimal
maximums in the show notes so you can
copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you like
and now you can find all of our minimal
maxims in one place thanks to
our good friend jessica lynn williams
minimal maxims.com
all right we got a question from anka
are there ways to transform vacant malls
into something valuable for the
community
yes and i think we should yeah and so
before i get into my pithy answer here
i want to talk about this because we
have some spaces now
we're seeing this happen now and this is
a better use than just leaving it sit
there
decaying and rotting although i think
sometimes that's beautiful i love
looking at
detroit at its at a sort of bottom
which was somewhere around i don't know
2010
like 2009 and the malls the libraries
yeah there's some like schools of
libraries beautiful things
oh my gosh yeah it did there in fact
sean there's a photo essay i don't
remember if it was in slate or new york
times but it was somewhere
the photo essay of new york or of
detroit rather
from about a decade ago and it's
stunning and there's something stunning
about that decay but
we do want to reuse many of these spaces
we can now
a lot of these malls are being bought by
amazon and they're being turned into
distribution centers
now there's a good reason for them to do
it it's actually better for the
environment if they do it
because a few things one is they don't
have to build a whole new space
they get to re-use this space which is
which is
better than if they were to build
something right next to it right right
but also it's right next to the highway
so they don't have to drive 15
20 minutes off of the highway which uses
more fuel
it produces more carbon yeah dioxide etc
and and so it's better for the
environment overall
however i think there are so many other
better uses
that's one use and and and if that's
going to work then great i know they're
buying up a lot of
malls and turning them into distribution
centers
i would love to see it's my great hope
that we could see a giant dent
get put into the homeless crisis by
re-appropriating
malls it's a great idea into homeless
centers with uh services
and uh testing and and medical services
and and food and and sleeping quarters
as a transitionary space
back to non-homeless life right yeah
and because i i mean i have so much
compassion
there's there's such a problem here
especially in southern california
i think about a fourth i think it's a
fourth of the homeless population in the
countries in california
yeah in one state it's crazy and and so
there's a large homeless problem here
and
i think that we could address it by
using some of these empty spaces that
are
not ever going to come back right and
that's the thing we have to recognize
this is fluid as i talked about earlier
we built these things to think they
would be permanent
and they could be permanent structures
but the use is not going to be permanent
right and so i think we can transform
them i also think that we are missing
out a little
bit on community space because these
were
the one benefit of the malls you
remember when we were teens we would go
hang out at malls all the time yeah i go
to the middletown mall
me and my brother went there like
several times yeah yeah you used to go
all the time
yeah yeah and so i i spent a lot of time
and now if you look at the middletown
mall you got to see the video i mean
it's
terrifying man ryan so ryan managed a
store in
in middletown uh it's in between
cincinnati middle town
and and so you i think you have to
you have to look and say what is the
best use of of these spaces
can they be transformed into experience
spaces
i think in some cases yes can they
become more
town squares yes our friend rob bell
who's been on the podcast a couple times
we've been on his podcast the robcast
he's written 10 books but before he uh
before
he well before he moved to california he
was a mega church pastor
his church was in a mall an old donated
mall and so it was an abandoned mall
that they donated him and i think 98
maybe
and and so there are a lot of things we
can do with these
spaces that are shockingly more
intentional
than consumerism yeah than the shopping
mall itself
yeah yeah and so here's my pithy answer
for you almost anything
is more valuable than consumerism
and uh so i i wrote this other thing
down here i don't know if it's a minimal
uh minimal maximum or not abandoned
malls are consumerism
at its terminus an empty carapace
brimming with nostalgia
not meaning and i think there's
something about that
when ryan so in the dayton arcade
yeah so you and i we're finishing up
this new film with matt diabella
called less is now yeah and it part of
it surrounds
it's i don't know 15 minutes of it now
is around this talk that you and i went
out and gave a bunch of times
we only used a few excerpts from that
talk at this point but we wanted to give
that talk originally in an abandoned
mall
right we just found that it was going to
be really difficult but we finally found
one we found the dayton arcade in in
in downtown dayton uh
proper and and it's this beautiful
abandoned structure it's been abandoned
i think since 89
beautiful decaying mall yes yeah and
there's something just gorgeous about it
in fact we we had secured it we took two
trips out there we did some filming
inside it we were getting ready to film
the talk
and then they found all this asbestos oh
yeah and it was like
oh like we can't have a whole crew of
people here exposed to asbestos for
12 or 14 hours a day yeah that's that
you know 30 years from now they'll have
mesothelioma
it would not be a good thing yeah and so
we had to let let that go even though it
was gorgeous although
i think parts of that will still make
make it into the
the film itself there are other malls
that we wanted to use we went and
actually toured some other abandoned
malls
they just didn't work aesthetically
because they weren't decaying yet so it
just looked
weird it looked like it looked like
someone closed them all for us to film
in it and
it didn't work but we ended up finding a
better space anyway so
it worked out really well and i also
wrote about
the dayton arcade in our next book love
people use things and it got cut
somewhere between the third and the
fourth draft that
that section did so i think i'm gonna
read it on the maxwell episode because
there's this whole metaphor about
abandoned malls and how we've abandoned
ourselves
i'm really excited for the uh renovation
of the dayton arcade
yes well let's talk about how they're
going to use it because i think that
that perfectly
um that perfectly addresses on
or monica's question here um you've been
there
yeah so talk about the space what it
looked like it looks post-apocalyptic
it's got like escalators that are
decaying and these
high gl uh ceilings that are glass with
i guess wire or copper like framing and
um again looks post-apocalyptic uh
you know old stores where you could tell
it was like a sneaker store because you
can just barely see half of a sign that
you can make out the word sneaker
yeah um a lot of old abandoned office
spaces
yeah it's it is uh it's truly beautiful
but
it's weird though because we keep
calling these decaying moths beautiful
it's beautiful for the wrong reasons
though
yeah well i think the thing about the
dayton arcade and we'll go into this
more on the maximal is
it wasn't originally a mall it was a
community space
yeah and this was in it it was actually
built way before malls were ever
even invented right it was an indoor and
outdoor
community space there were there was a
market there were offices there there
were apartments
it was the shared living space and
eventually
consumerism took over creed's a cover
yes
and and but now here's the thing it is
being repurposed it's being reclaimed
and because the architecture is some of
the most stunning architecture i've ever
seen
absolutely go ahead and google date and
arcade or we'll put a link to their
website and
in the show notes but they it is it's
amazing what they're doing but they're
turning into a co-working space that
there are going to be some shops in
there but it's not going to be retail
centric it's going to be
like a market commission yeah yeah and
so uh there's a technology lab that's
going in there from the university of
dayton
apartments people they're going to use
it as a community space again
and part of that does involve consuming
but it doesn't involve
consumerism right and i think we need to
make that distinction
and so i think the dayton arcade is
actually the best example of what we can
do
when we we take a structure and we
repurpose it
in a way that is better for the
community and
and doesn't encourage us to over indulge
or to over consume yeah when i read this
question it made me think about
you know reusing things in general and i
think it's always
better to reuse something if you can uh
or repurpose it
yeah so uh my pithy answer is this
reusing is better than recycling
recycling is better than refuse refuse
is better than refusing to let go
hmm yeah because sometimes we get caught
up in that well it's going to go on a
landfill
and it's like well you should have
thought about that before you bought it
right uh if i would argue that the
landfill is a better spot to put it than
in your closet because in your closet
it's not going to decay
as rapidly right it's not going to be
able to uh
yeah to decay with the rest of the trash
if you're holding on to it then it's
just taking up space and you're just
keeping it around longer
man there's so much more i want to talk
to you about we got some listener tips
today
we got a really great added value
segment ryan you are going to love this
it involves a a friend of the podcast
but we first we have a bunch more
surprise questions this week
how much retail space does america have
compared to the rest of the world
man this is staggering ryan i've got
some stats for you okay what other
beacons of consumerism do you see
dissipa disappearing or evolving in the
coming years
is shopping america's biggest religion
if we turn them all into a museum of
consumerism what exhibits would be in it
this is going to be a fun thought
experiment also how can we
replace shopping with meaningful
experiences
and what experiences plus we got a
million more questions about
shopping about dead and dying malls and
so much more for the minimalists and if
you want to hear all that
check out our maximal episodes on the
minimalists private podcast it's a
completely separate podcast
it's just two bucks and it's the most
honest way for the minimalists to earn
income because
we don't believe in advertisements we
think advertisements
are gross and so we make money only if
you find value in and support what we
create head on over to
theminimalists.com
support to subscribe and get a personal
link so that
our private podcast plays in your
favorite podcast app
ryan what else you got for us this week
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners
check them out hi my name is daniel and
i live in charlotte north carolina
in previous podcasts i've heard people
wanting to do more for the environment
but not knowing how they can contribute
i've been using the search engine called
ecosia
that's the letter e c o
s i a dot org ecosia.org
this search engine plants trees with its
ad revenue
and while i do agree that advertisements
suck to me
it's a small inconvenience to pay for a
great contribution
for searches i'd be doing anyway on the
internet
they have already planted over 17
million trees across the globe and they
post monthly
video updates on youtube hi this is
lauren i live in new orleans
i was cleaning out my clothes closet and
dresser this morning
and wanted to share my tip for keeping a
minimalist wardrobe
so in my dresser and my closet i have
stacks
of items underwear socks shirts
shorts jeans etc all of my different
clothing items are in stacks
when i do laundry i put the clean items
at the bottom of each stack so the items
that i haven't worn most recently
end up at the top of the stack and i
tried to choose items to
wear from the top each day that way if i
find myself
not well not willing to wear something
that's on the top of the stack
because i don't like it anymore or it
doesn't fit anymore
then i know it's probably time to get
rid of it
i also do this with my hanging clothes i
will put the laundered items on the
right side
and try to choose items to wear from the
left side so they're also constantly
rotating consequently i only had a small
bag of items to get rid of during
today's purge because i wear
most of the items that i own all right
y'all for our added value
this week ryan our friend matt nathanson
who had one of our favor my favorite
podcasts ever yeah
he's so good i mean it just so happens
he's a phenomenal musician
he's also when we saw him live i think
it was
that night after we did a podcast with
him and
um he he has such a great live show he's
like a stand-up comic
well i generally hate live albums i
think they're not as good
as yeah this is an exception he just put
out a live album awesome
it's called live in paradise boston
that's great and here's the thing the
album has 61
songs on it and i think about half of
them
were recorded in boston and it's
mostly acoustic uh songs but there's so
much
life in these songs and he you get to
see his like
stand-up comedy prowess in between the
uh songs so he does these little
sketches but he
he then put another 30 or so songs on
there from other
live events throughout that entire tour
so it could be he was in
fairfax or he was in columbus or
wherever he was and he was
doing these shows and he would take
songs from here or there and there's so
much energy
in life in these like i feel like i
could just
i could sit around the house all day and
just enjoy
this entire album but i think he made it
so robust
because he wanted you to make sort of
your own playlist out of it because if
you have 61 songs
make it your own what would be the
perfect 10 song
album for you all 61 of your favorite
songs then none of them are your
favorite songs that's right
so check it out matt nathanson makes me
think of uh when he opened up for us in
boston remember that debacle with
that's when we started to be like oh
crap we can't do these like little
meetups anymore
yeah yeah we we had we just had so many
uh yeah
it was like that whole tour though yeah
what a lot of surprises yeah yeah good
surprises for sure
but yeah anyway matt nathanson it is
called live in paradise
boston let us know what you think about
it comment on youtube i'd love to hear
your thoughts about the album and real
quick for right here right now here's
one thing that's going on in the life of
the minimalist actually two things
so let's talk about community spaces and
and i know that we're in the middle of
this pandemic but there's going to be a
time when we come out of it and i think
even now
what we're finding is we need we need
support from other people
and so ryan and i back when we were in
2014 speaking of that tour
we went to a hundred different cities
and in each city we left behind a free
local meetup group and these are people
who aren't necessarily minimal some of
them are some of them are but they talk
about decluttering they talk about
careers they talk about
health and life and everything in
between relationships
and it's called minimalist.org that is
the website
and you can go there you can find your
city there's a hundred different cities
eight different countries
but there's also right now there's an
this is especially valuable
there's an online city as well yeah so
even if you don't have
a city near you but if you do let's say
you live in saskatoon and we left behind
a
a meet-up group in saskatoon and you
want to meet
with those people they're just just a
group you meet online
until you're able to meet in person
again and you can interact with people
locally even if you're not next to them
and eventually when things open back up
you can start meeting with open-minded
people locally i say that specifically
not
like-minded people they might have
different beliefs from you and i think
that's great
ryan and i aren't like-minded but we're
both open-minded we're
open to each other's beliefs yeah so
check that out minimalist.org also i
thought i'd give you an update
uh this past weekend we just closed we
did 48 hours
a record for my writing class nice i'm
really shocked by
but so if you didn't get into the
writing class too bad for you i'm sorry
it's not opening back up anytime soon
um this isn't one of those things where
it's like oh i'm gonna extend it for
three more days act now
nope sorry you are you're out of luck
right now
uh but congratulations if you did make
it in i'm looking forward to
to well by the time this comes out in a
couple weeks or next week whenever it
comes out
um we'll already be interacting at that
point but really looking forward to the
class
uh some some great questions coming in
so far from the students
but if you're interested in a future
class i'll notify you whenever
whenever we decide to open it up again i
usually do it a couple times
a year but in the meantime if you do
want to learn how to write better i've
got a free ebook called 11
ways to write better and if you download
that i'll also
inform you via email whenever the class
opens back up of course we'll never ever
send you spam or junk or advertisements
or anything like that
but if you want the 11 ways to write
better ebook
it's howtorightbetter.org you can follow
the minimalists on facebook twitter and
instagram at the minimalist come to one
of our live podcast shows visit
theminimalists.com tour to find a city
near you
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast email a
voice memo to podcast
at theminimalists.com you can comment on
this episode at youtube.com
the minimalist and if you want our show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at the
minimalists.com you'll also receive our
simple sunday emails but never spam
never junk
nothing disgusting and if you leave here
today with just one message we hope it's
this
love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it